day have you taken the business to seven
figures
[Music]
hello Hello nice to meet you nice to
meet you too
my name's Leila Layla yes very nice to
meet you my name's Jonathan nice to meet
you have a seat thank you very much how
you doing today I'm great
good good good just enjoying this lovely
London summer
yeah
so
we're here on a date here we are indeed
I feel privileged to be sitting here
really I feel like the privilege is all
mine
you're so beautiful I feel like I'm
actually underdressed I need to um maybe
have a vest under here or something
yeah you don't need much to look good I
think
I think tell me about yourself Layla so
um I'm a model full-time I'm a full-time
model and
I live in Brighton Brighton and which is
a Seaside City Seaside City yes
um it's so beautiful there and I highly
recommend it I've heard the best fish
and chips is in Brighton it is
because okay so let me let me tell you
something as an American
um you know I've got a little bit of an
ethnic background okay so I've had some
poppies traditional chip fish and chips
here and it was just so Bland when I ate
it in London yeah yeah
so I was kind of asking the local
londoners I said hey so is all fish and
chips kind of bland they said yeah
unless you go to Brighton I love that
yeah that's what they told me I was like
where's Brighton and they kind of uh
took me down the path of understanding
that no I love that I'm kind of glad
especially from America as well that's
crazy that Brighton's been said to you
you know it's a lovely Place do they
season the fish and chips in Brighton I
don't think they do it's just very fresh
it's literally from the sea so you can
tell if it's frozen or if it's been
cooked the same day oh wow so in London
obviously it's going to be frozen it's
not going to be the same day oh is it
Frozen
it is most stuff from London isn't it oh
wow see I'm just a naive American coming
here to be taken advantage by this city
have a second
day I'm I'm okay I'm okay to do that
definitely we
so from London how far is Brighton I
have hours something like that depending
on where you are in London of course if
you're kind of east side then it's a
little bit quicker but um in general
it's about two hours
which isn't bad to be by the Sea yeah
you know what I mean it's it's so lovely
in the summer as well especially wow
well I'm from I'm from Florida and so
I'm a very ocean-centric person myself
yeah I have to be
me too me too I get depressed if I don't
if I don't see the ocean like once every
quarter
no I'm the same I grew up in the country
like on a kind of a farm we had geese
chickens wow and it was by the Sea as
well in Sussex which is not far from
Brighton Eva right so always been having
that around me them surroundings is why
I moved to Brighton because it's got the
same kind of area really it's the shape
I to say really yeah
yeah well you're I feel like you're very
lucky because I'm actually I'm looking
for a traditional woman
I am I I I really don't trust big
corporations and control of our food and
all of these things you know I want to
have
um some chickens on my property to give
us fresh eggs every day
and I'm at the right girl I think so I
think so I'll tell you something now as
well my mum has chickens does she he has
ten and I have fresh eggs
oh I'm jealous I'm so jealous I'm so
jealous well you know the average woman
doesn't necessarily carry around a bunch
of fresh eggs in a purse I want to hold
it against you
I mean if you would have been my top
pick if you showed up here with some
organic eggs for me for our second date
we'll do that I'm ready I'm super ready
so I am looking for a little bit more of
a traditional girl in the sense of she's
ready to just live a traditional life
with me okay you know I want to have
children
so I'm 37. okay so personally I'm going
to take some accountability
um personally I feel like I played
around a little too long and um you like
freedom I wouldn't I wouldn't say I'm
gonna be free no matter what age I am
but I do feel like
I should have started to have children
maybe three to five years ago right
and so now I don't want to put a woman
in position where I'm just like
that's and that's the thing because I I
don't want to enter a relationship where
I'm putting a pressure on anybody my
employees my family the woman I love
right because it's never fun to be under
pressure would you agree it is
definitely I think it depends on
what is what you want absolutely
match in what you want
you want as well
as well yeah yeah so
yeah you need you need the special one
to stay straight away well tonight
they're the one I guess yeah so how
would you feel how would you feel if we
let's say we went on a date and you're
just like man you know this american guy
you know American guy this american guy
he doesn't say crisp he says potato
chips
you know you know he has a little bit of
a accent that's foreign to you do you
like I feel yeah well I feel like it
could work out but what if you feel like
when we started dating everything was
clicking right the chemistry everything
was going good and I said Layla listen
you're a beautiful young woman
you know you have a lovely face you're
very cute you have good you have a
wonderful family you know you were
raised in geese and all these things or
in these fresh eggs this is what I want
in my life
and I want to give you a child and I
want to start a family with you
how would you feel about that I would be
willing but the thing is with me I do
love my freedom yeah so if if like say
if we had a child I'd like to know that
I can still kind of more of a social
life I'd like start a social life but
obviously be the most amazing lover that
I will be yeah
um and as well depending on how many you
want I want five boys ideally
so you would have to be pregnant for
about seven years
so let's say let's say let's let's say
we start we start now and then
everything goes well and you're 24 now
right yeah yeah so you're 24. you're
absolutely gorgeous well if it rains my
beautiful body yeah I mean I don't think
it would I've got good shape i i i
a woman like you I will make a way you
know
it would be fun I'll make a way I will
make a way and so you know let's say we
start dating now theoretically you're 24
let's say from 24 let's say 24 to 26 we
date for about a year and a half then
after 26 is when I start talking about
so 26 we decide we're just so in love
with each other let's just start making
babies and let's just start making this
big family and I I don't want to live in
the city okay I want to live in the
countryside
I want to get a big house
with air conditioning definitely
so let me ask you this okay
if I'm gonna provide everything for you
and I'm going to take care of you no
matter what will you follow me no matter
where we go
indeed really do you know why it's
because I want to travel the world as
well
can you just put a rig on my finger
already do you have an onion we have
onion rings here
you know we honestly speaking so here's
and I'm going to be very honest with you
okay
I would like to have five boys
and
if we have those five boys I would like
to raise them in America but we can come
here to Mariel England
because I want to teach the boys how to
use guns I love that I want to teach the
boys how to fight I want to teach the
boys how to chop wood I want to teach
the boys how to be real men in this
world
of men with limp wrists and Limp other
parts to say the least you're not
you're not so I want to raise them to be
proper strong men and the benefit for
you Leila is you have me and five other
strapping young men
we're going to take care of you forever
you're going to be the most protected
woman on the planet
you know how can you not say nice that
that's what I'm trying to say it's true
boys do you run in my family so I'm the
youngest child well
is side that actually works out that
actually works out even more because I
was saying you know an earlier date that
I'm the oldest okay and so there's a
book called the birth order book
and it says the best dating
compatibility is when you're the
youngest you get with the oldest
because I dated a girl who was also the
old yeah
yeah I dated a girl who was the oldest
before and it was just conflict conflict
she it was just it was so exhausting
because your same level almost
she was always arguing and I always had
to tell her why she was wrong and it was
a joke
I just had to let her know why she was
wrong and it was just exhausting
compared to I feel like the youngest of
the
the the litter if you will right they're
just a lot more open-minded they're a
lot more yeah exactly you know they
don't have like when you're the oldest
you have to be like you're stressed out
I gotta be the top dog I gotta protect
everything against each other all the
time right I mean and it's nice to have
guidance sometimes from someone who's
much more mature and older than you you
know and the thing is too oh sorry go
ahead no no you're going that's why I
love the the youngest you guys you're so
you're so very just compatible but the
biggest thing is with the youngest too
everybody loves the youngest they never
hate the youngest kids were in our Prime
Time right loving we have opportunity
waiting for us in life yeah and I feel
like when you're with someone it's the
same age it's a bit boring yeah I need
to give you that excitement in life yeah
and that buzz and I feel like when
someone's the same age as you
same you need that excitement and
adrenaline and adrenaline sorry yeah I
definitely agree with you yeah I
definitely agree
ment and you know you just have such
good you're okay it's okay you have you
have you have a great feminine energy
about you thank you you have good things
um why don't you just tell me a little
bit more about yourself what are you
doing nowadays what do you do for
yourself yeah no of course so I do my
modeling full time
um I also featured on X on the beach a
couple loads and months ago the most
recent season which was an amazing
experience and I learned a lot about
myself and love in general and love in
general
how did you learn about love from this
modeling experience
not the modeling it was just being on
the show I went on with my ex now at the
time but we were together when we went
on X on the beach so I'm not familiar
with X on the beach what is this
I love Island okay it's a reality show
yeah
oh cool
comes out with your ex or he was your ex
at the time so
oh
so yeah it was very wow the situation
and atmosphere is just you can't imagine
it and we were in The Villa for around
six weeks constant
um but I just learned a lot about myself
and that I all I need is myself wow in
life you know you don't always need a
man
um and even though love is important you
need to learn to love yourself first
before you love anything absolutely
um so yeah it was a big thing to do but
I'm glad I did it wow I know more now
what I want in life
um and just the experience of it oh yeah
wow I think that's really cool I think
that when a person can be very
introspective about themselves it's a
very rare quality yeah and I of course
it makes you just realize more about
life and to just appreciate the things
around you more simple things instead of
just trying too hard I think so what did
you realize when you were on the show
the
I don't the thing is with me I like to
be respected as a woman and I didn't get
that from Eva I don't know if it was
just being on TV how it changed all of
us
how did they disrespect you
do any fans
do you yeah
yeah what kind of what kind of uh now
the conversations got a little
feel a little hot over here
[Music]
so what's go what's going on on the only
fans and
I I do
sexy content okay
this is a judgment-free Zone it's a
judgment freezer I'm a digital marketer
myself so the numbers are clicking for
me I'm just thinking if we got together
I could probably probably 10x this
business honestly definitely
Sam's past
as well but I believe I just have a
certain image to myself like some girls
where you come across quite sexual or
feminine like you said about me yeah
um and it's a money making machine yeah
it's changed my life
um but coming back to the whole respect
thing that's why men don't take me
seriously yeah I do it it doesn't bother
me but it does because I would like to
find someone yeah in my life but it does
get in the way sometimes of what I do
have you taken the business to seven
figures
I've most I've made this
I'm sorry
a year yeah I think that's good it's a
start it's a good start
um I've only been doing it about a year
okay it's yeah but I want to be on 30k a
month yeah more than that yeah well if
you have that mindset of I want to be on
this per month it will happen yeah I
will be on that
really
um so yes but I don't want to do it
forever when do you see yourself hanging
up the only Fan's hat
when you're famous
do you want to be famous yeah
famous for what
I want to do just modeling I want to be
a beauty icon like Marilyn Audrey
Hepburn wow even in film any opportunity
that gets given to me I just want to
take and that's what I've always done in
life so far is just take everything you
know yeah because you never know when
the next thing's gonna happen kind of
seeing what's wrong before now so what
if I said Layla listen we've gone on a
couple dates and I respect you for who
you are as an individual
but I just want you to give this all up
and I want to give you children and I
want to take care of you
and I want to make sure everything's
sorted but you would have to give up
your dreams of being famous in order to
be a loving wife and a nurturing mother
to our beautiful children for the rest
of your life
what's the lifestyle
traveling
is easy I'm traveling right now
I mean you're hearing okay
I'm heading to LA next week after that
it's the Philippines then Thailand then
back to Tokyo you know I'm Janice yeah
well let me ask you this so let's talk
about that real quick okay what if I
said I wanted to take you traveling
around the world yeah right but we had
to stay in airbnbs no I'd be happy with
that would you things like that don't
bother me so I'm not really a
materialistic girl people think that of
that I mean I mean I'm not jumping to
any conclusions
of course not but I don't know maybe
it's just because of what I do or
whatever but I love when we when I was
little we used to go camping quite a bit
like in caravan yeah I'm intense like I
love that I wouldn't want to be stuck in
a hotel yeah I want to feel where I am
in the environment or like go to Africa
and actually live with the tribes wow
you know and experience how they live
yeah instead of sitting in a hotel room
wow that's cool so you're very kind and
giving woman it seems yes I'm very
caring
Karen so I feel like if I really laid
down the American charm
I said if I said potato chips a bunch of
times instead of Chris my favorite words
you know if I if I really laid it down I
feel like you would maybe join me and
give me some beautiful white children
and we would have just this beautiful
family this very International family
between the UK and the United States
that's that's even better that's even
better you know
are you I'm sorry I just thought you
were completely white it's okay Turkish
okay and so my mom's dad was fully
Turkish wow
wow yeah I'm still obviously English but
that's where my name Layla comes from as
well oh wow that's so cool
American from you yeah English and a bit
Turkish I feel like this could work I
feel like this could work
well listen Layla you are a beautiful
very smart very eloquent young lady it
was wonderful to meet you
say it was so it was truly
my pleasure to meet you my pleasure to
meet you thank you so much stuff I
really enjoyed it maybe we'll see you
soon oh definitely
I hope so bright I hope so
so I think the date actually went really
well I think Jonathan's a lovely guy
um and I'd love to see him again I want
to take him to Brighton and her fish and
chips together
I reckon I give him about an eight to
nine
um he's very respectful as a man and
because he's so mature as well that's
what I love about him I would definitely
go on a second date with Jonathan for
sure and I can't wait to meet up with
him again